der hafen von sassnitz auf rügen kapitän
kyle prise witz sticht mit seinem
fischkutter in see begleitet von einem
schwesterschiff es ist märz er nimmt zum
letzten mal in diesem frühjahr kurs auf
die heringsfang runde in der ostsee das
geschäft ist schwierig geworden die
heringsbestände haben stark abgenommen
die fischer dürfen nur noch selten raus
fahren und sie fragen sich was aus ihnen
werden soll
sicherlich mag ich besorgen wenn ich
sehe was passiert ob ich meinen job
die nächsten zehn jahre noch ausüben
kann aber das wird zukunft zeigen und
ich bin der letzte der die flinte nicht
nur der hering bereitet probleme
auch die dorsche werden weniger im juli
2009 10 zog die eu-kommission die
notbremse und verhängte ein totales
fangverbot damit hatte kein riese witz
nicht gerechnet
wenn dann ein sofortiges dort frank
verbot ausgesprochen wird dann wird uns
die existenzgrundlage von einem tag zum
anderen dazu heute nacht aber hat der
fischer aus sassnitz glück rund 55
tonnen hering gehen ihm ins netz die
nachtfahrt hat sich gelohnt prise witz
würde am liebsten morgen wieder raus
doch das geht nicht
er hat seine fangquote fast ausgeschöpft
und nun fordern meeresbiologen sogar ein
totales fangverbot auch für den hering
in der ostsee
warum werden die bestände immer geringer
an der überfischung liegt es nicht
allein
fest steht die ostsee wird durch den
klimawandel immer wärmer
die temperatur stieg in den letzten 30
jahren nur um 1,5 grad für die heringe
bedeutet die erwärmung nichts gutes der
fortpflanzungs system gerät
durcheinander
ihre existenz ist bedroht
warum das so ist erforschen biologe
patrick polte und seine crew
sie haben festgestellt dass die heringe
immer früher leichen
sie werden von dem warmen wasser
angelockt zu früh denn für den nachwuchs
fehlt es noch an futter eigentlich ist
es so dass diese kleinen larven wenn ihr
aus dem ei schlüpfen dann brauchen die
plankton futter und zwar relativ
spezielles plankton futter weil die
mäuler so klein sind dass da nicht alles
durch passt das heißt das muss zur
richtigen zeit das richtige futter
verfügbar sein
und vielleicht kommt es dann einfach zu
spät nun wenn die larven schon im
februar anfang märz schlüpfen dann
wachsen die noch nicht in diese
planktonblüte rein das ist im moment die
haupt vermutung dass die dann einfach
verhungern
unterwegs mit dem forschungsschiff club
er das ziel der greifswalder bodden das
leicht gebiet der heringe nicht nur die
erwärmung sondern auch der dünger aus
der landwirtschaft setzt dem hering zu
das wasser ist dadurch häufig trübe den
wasserpflanzen fehlt das sonnenlicht die
proben zeigen die anzahl der larven geht
zurück die kinderstube der heringe wird
immer kleiner
früher wuchsen diese wasserpflanzen noch
bis in eine tiefe von zirka acht meter
der ganze boden war voll mit
wasserpflanzen zeit der jährigen konnte
überall seine eier festkleben
heutzutage sind diese wasserpflanzen auf
den auf die uferzone beschränkt da wo
noch das licht tief genug eindringen
kann das dass ich nicht mehr so tief
eindringt liegt halt an dieser
nährstoffbelastung und dadurch haben wir
diesen relativ schmalen wasserpflanzen
streifen
stattdessen blühen die alben im juli
vergangenen jahres bildeten sich riesige
algenteppiche einige von ihnen wirken
toxisch auf die herings laufen und der
perfekte dünger für die algen kommt aus
der landwirtschaft ludwig hirschberg ist
landwirt 30 kilometer von der ostsee bei
plön erstrecken sich die äcker der
hirschbergs angebaut werden raps mais
und weizen die felder denkt er im
frühjahr damit die pflanzen kräftig
wachsen
aber wenn es zu heiß wird und so wenig
regen fällt hat er ein problem wenn die
pflanzen jetzt eben nicht weiter wachsen
sondern durch die trockenheit
vertrocknen dann nutzen wir auch den
stickstoff den genen im boden zur
verfügung stellen leider nicht aus und
der wird dann über herbst und winter aus
dem boden ausgewaschen das ist die
gefährdung von grundwasser die will auch
hirschberg nicht doch durch den
klimawandel geschieht genau dass der
dünger den wir aufs feld streuen der
dann von den pflanzen nicht aufgenommen
wird
der westen eben mit der zeit in den
unterboden ab und offen geht dann über
die grundwasserleiter in die gewässer
wie zum beispiel hier dem bielersee der
ja mit der ostsee verbunden ist ja über
die alte schwentine haben und
verschiedene andere sehen ist
tatsächlich dieser see am ende mit der
ostsee verbunden
hier im labor des schleswig
holsteinischen umweltamtes wird der
zustand von seen bächen und flüssen
untersucht dabei greifen die
wissenschaftler auf ein ganzes netz von
messpunkten zurück wir erhalten ca 4000
gewässerproben im jahr also insofern hat
man schon einen recht guten überblick
geschaffen über das ganze land die
proben zeigen die belastung durch
nährstoffe hat nicht abgenommen wie
versprochen und erforderlich die
gewässer in schleswig holstein sind
durch ackerbau und viehzucht weiter
stark in mitleidenschaft gezogen
in dem nährstoff bericht heißt es schon
für die jahre bis 2017 das zitat die
fließgewässer belastung mit stickstoff
nahezu flächendeckend die
orientierungswerte überschreitet und
weiter heißt es die tatsächliche
überdüngung beträgt somit eine
größenordnung von etwa 50 prozent
auf dem weg nach dänemark
auch im nachbarland spielen ackerbau und
viehzucht eine große rolle
anders als in deutschland haben die
dänen ihren landwirten wegen der
wasserbelastung strenge regeln auferlegt
wie etwa johannes caspar
jedes jahr werden auf seinem hof 27.000
schweine gemästet und eine entsprechende
menge kohle produziert maskat besitzt
auch äcker auf denen er die gülle aus
bringt das aber wird streng überwacht
ich glaube die regeln hier sind sehr
strikt es wird uns genau vorgeschrieben
wie viel stickstoff pro hektar
ausbringen dürfen
es gibt regeln wir unsere anlagen gebaut
sein müssen
ich glaube da sind wir den deutschen
landwirten wohl voraus die gülle wird
chemisch aufbereitet dass schädliche
ammoniak gas wird gebunden der gestank
verschwindet das gas gelangt nicht mehr
in die luft die gülle kann effektiver
als dünger eingesetzt werden belastet
das wasser deutlich weniger wie das
system funktioniert sehr gut ich bin
glücklich damit
und ich sehe es auch auf dem acker die
aufbereitete gülle wird von den pflanzen
gut aufgenommen
ich habe eine bessere ernte die
eu-kommission empfiehlt das verfahren
auch um die ostsee zu schützen
deutschland aber zieht nicht mit will
die landwirte nicht dazu verpflichten
zurückzog ein riesiges erst im herbst
darf der fischer wieder auf heringsfang
gehen er macht sich sorgen um seine
zukunft
wenn das so weitergeht muss man angst
haben weil einem die existenzgrundlage
genommen wird heißt das eigentlich das
aus für die fischerei und so könnten
dies schon bald die letzten bilder vom
hering in der ostsee sein
[Musik]